take a chill pill melt some metal in the
palm of your hand and enter doormat
because loot is back
cook your morning eggs outside with the
help of soul source a device that allows
you to harness the sun's energy to cook
anything you want from fried eggs to
steaks without any outside power source
you can even cook a hamburger shaped
like a hot dog or just eat a boatload of
salad of course you'll also need your
morning coffee wait no i guess you will
grumpy cat no bug if you just need to
power your phone outside you can use
this powerpot thermoelectric generator
just boil water inside the pot and use
the heat to generate enough electricity
to power your phone in the same amount
of time as a conventional outlet this
sort of thing would be great for the
zombie apocalypse which you can join in
by outfitting yourself with shirts from
electric zombie with zombie road
warriors and even zombie shirts for your
dog but until the apocalypse you'll
still have to go to work so keep the
party going from last night with this
hypno cube for your desk it's a 3d
animated display of lights that will
help you relax by staring deep into its
hypnotic glow
to keep things hidden at the workplace
just throw them away into your dumpster
keepsake box that looks almost as fly as
your rainbow keyboard or your
interactive ferrofluid sculpture deemed
the lava lamp of the 21st century
instead of a desk maybe you should work
off of this alien table
or just take a nap in your viking ship
bed
wear some custom shoes from
morethanart2wear.com that include air
jordan poison dart frog shoes and double
happiness or customize your own
cardboard robot arms with this
do-it-yourself kit over at etsy that has
everything you'll need to finally have
giant cardboard arms pigeon mask ipong
is a ping pong training buddy that will
help improve your skills it has the
ability to oscillate and create top spin
on the ball preparing you to school your
friends for the first time and
potentially last time ever two romanian
bear skeletons are being sold for 85 000
i found them on this incredible website
called tell me where on earth dot com
that not only has rare bear fossils for
sale but all kinds of oddities such as
moose poop earrings african meteorite
fragments or the largest cave bear skull
weight what it's sold
if you don't want the real thing just
buy some of these anatomically correct
and to scale dinosaurs carved by galileo
hernandez nunez at genemodels.com
but in order to buy any of this stuff
you could use some cold hard cash
oh or one of the 10 credit cards the
obtainium wallet can hold recently
backed on kickstarter these wallets are
made to be durable small and handsome
holding as much as a normal wallet
without the chance of it stretching out
losing your stuff or getting damaged
look cool with your new wallet but smart
with your classic books tablet cover
available in the great gatsby alice in
wonderland and great expectations and
now it's time to hit the eject button
light switch and as always thanks for
watching
our island
i'll get you there